my name is dave year
[Music]
i'm
currently a research analyst at acronium
asset management
um
we're
an institutional asset mentor um with a
quantitative
investment model
and um prior to that
i've been working mostly on nlp
and um yeah
so uh this is my specialty of performing
as well
and um today i'm going to talk about
analyzing company filings for
stock selections
so um my talk is subtitled the practical
report um because uh rather than
presenting new findings um i would like
to share with you our experience working
with uh company filings um
as well as some of the insights we
gained and some of the challenges that
we faced in the process
from a practitioner's perspective and
anecdotally
this was
the first project acronium that was
implemented in python and i'm happy to
say that we're currently rewriting our
entire research code base in python so
this was definitely a success
right so iconium we are always looking
for new ways to gain information about
stock prices
and um
there's a different ways of
getting such information from textual
data
one of the
most well-known ways i suppose would be
from company related news such as the
ones shown here about wirecards
suspected forging of contracts which
broke in january 2019
and if we look at
wirecard's
stock value which is the brown
curve you can see in the graph here you
see that there's a sharp drop
in the value of wirecard by 30
uh when the news is unreported
but um
excuse me i can't read my presentation
so
uh
um
we can also see that this uh effect
happens very very quickly after the news
breaks um so the effective company uses
uh
usually a short-term trading signal
and at coding we are looking for more
long-term signals so we chose to work in
another source of textual information
which is
company filings
and before i dive into and give you a
very brief overview
of our stock selection model
um so
what we are using is a
linear model that takes it input what we
call factors or
features i guess
um that are based on company and stock
characteristics um and then we
based on uh historic stock returns we
learned a linear model uh our linear
model weights for all of those features
and the prediction time take the current
functional values combine them with the
weights and obtain
a prediction for each stock
of the stocks expected the return which
we call alpha
so um
to give you an overview of the factors
that are used in our current model
um
the as i said the alpha signal estimates
the expected outperformance of stocks
based on a combination of factors and
these can be attributed to three groups
the first is value which measures the
stock price relative to companies
fundamental value
the second one is quality which looks at
whether company has stable growth and
earnings as well as low debt
and momentum which is a trend indicator
based on
historic stock price developments
so what we wanted to do in this project
is we wanted to combine our traditional
signals with additional information
from text data
um
and of course these uh
are constructed quite differently so the
value quality and momentum signal mainly
derived from balance sheet data and
historic stock prices
um and this information is provided by
data vendors uh in a numeric format
which is ready for database support
and when you want to
extract additional information from
unstructured text data of course this
requires a more involved process which
i'm going to talk about now
so um as i said we're looking for more
stable
signal
and we decided uh to focus on company
regulatory filings
is also supported by
some academic work that we included into
our
signal
and
these
regulatory filings contain financially
relevant disclosures to
shareholders of course they also contain
tables of numbers
but there are some ways to construct
signals that focus on what is between
the tables so the text must be of the
company filing
and these filings are quite useful
because
they cover basically the entire
u.s listed stocks because their um u.s
securities and exchange commission
requires listed companies to submit
annual and quarterly reports
which are called forms 10k and 10q
these reports are freely available in
text.html format from the etc online
database
and we also did a pilot on international
filings
however we found that acquiring these
reports is much more challenging
because they're usually only available
in pdf or even
scanned images
and much more costly because there's no
central source where you can easily
obtain them
so looking at the
volumes of filing the filings that we
analyzed um
of course when we want to integrate our
textual signal with our stock selection
model we require historical data for
estimation and back testing
um so we downloaded all the available
filings starting in 1994
and ended up processing
slightly over 600 000 quarterly reports
and almost 200 000 annual reports by 40
000
unique companies
we are also downloading uh filings
daily as they arrive
and for this it's uh quite interesting
to look at the reporting intensity so
the number of reports that are filed per
day
and here we can observe some clear
seasonal peaks uh the blue ones being um
the uh annual reports and the red ones
the quarterly reports you can see that
most firms file the annual reports from
february to april and the quarterly
reports are filed in
may august and november
um and of course it's good to be aware
of that to anticipate any uh potential
performance bottlenecks
so what's in the reports um
[Music]
all the u.s regulatory filings have to
follow a mandatory structure
and i have sketched this uh on the right
for the annual
filing from 10k so these documents
always start with a business description
that can be several
pages long
um followed by a description of risk
factors
how so all the risks that the company
identifies to the business
legal proceedings and other
other sections there are some sections
that only occur rarely
because they don't pertain to all the
companies and are therefore omitted
we decided to extract separate signals
from each section
because we wanted to give equal weight
to the diverse information that is
present in the different sections
regardless of their length
we extract the sections using either a
regular expression space parser
which focuses on the section titles
or html tags when available where we
look at the um
we identify the table of contents in the
html and then follow the links to the
individual sections
however this is not always available so
we need the other parts as a fallback
method
we also looked at international filings
and of course there is no unified
structure that we could extract from
them
so here's our
document processing pipeline
we download the filings from the edgar
database
we then extract the texts
where
for international filings we do a pdf to
text step or an ocr step depending on
the documents format
for the html
documents we filter any
non
textual entities such as
embedded images
and we segment the documents into the
sections where applicable using our
regular expression base and html
parsers
we finally store the raw sections in
azure glob storage
all of this processing is done in python
for the historic signal we computed this
in parallel on the spark cluster using
pi spark but are currently uh switching
over to uh to dusk as we found iceberg
to be
the daily processing can currently be
done on premise and we're switching to a
cloud but there is switching to cloud
environment and airflow
so um
we looked some somewhat more deeply at
the
section extraction coverage so as i said
we use this cascaded parser and coverage
of course is essential for constructing
a reliable signal and we found that with
a combined parser we could increase
the coverage of extracted sections by uh
28 on average so this
is quite a necessary step that we have
to do
and the coverage over time is monitored
for the daily extraction jobs to ensure
that we can catch any deviations in the
future
so to sum up the challenges in the
document processing step
were mainly the variation in report
format that requires different parsing
approaches and continuous monitoring and
data quality checks
um the historical extraction that
required parallel processing
the spikes in reporting activity that we
saw
and the pilot and international filings
when we found that there's no unified
structure and that we have to handle the
pdf format or
performance ocr step and the following
i'm going to focus on the us documents
so let me tell you a little bit about
how we constructed the text-based
signals so these have all been published
in academic literature and we tried them
out in our setting
so we start out with a
sentiment signal that measures the
tonality of the text
we do this in a very simple way based on
a sentiment dictionary that has been
compiled by domain experts and of course
the intuition is here that negative
sentiment would also be a negative
indicator for stock performance
um readability measures the ease of
understanding text here we combine
several simple metrics such as word
length silver count long sentence count
the use of passive noise the number of
complex words and others
and here the intuition is that if the
text gets
really complex there might be something
that is being obfuscated for example so
this would also be a negative indicator
the third metric is similarity here we
measure the difference between current
and past reports by the same company
we do this using a bag of words the
approach with the fixed english
vocabulary and tfidf weighting so we
give more weight to the words that occur
in few documents only and here the
intuition is also that big changes could
potentially point to the negative
development in the company
our final metric is competitiveness
um
this measures how much a company is
perceived as a competitor by others and
it's based on the mentions of firms in
the competition subsection of the annual
report
we extract all dimensions and then
construct a citation network between
firms and compute the page rank
algorithm
on this network in order to
give a weight or assign weight to each
company
so um in the following i'm going to
illustrate these metrics but before um
let me briefly show you our text
processing pipeline so we start from the
raw sections where we apply some
pre-processing filtering steps
um and then process the text into
different
representations
that we need to construct the different
metrics so for the readability we
require back of sentences for sentiment
the lack of words
for similarity we constructive ids
vectors and for competitiveness
we perform an entity extraction step
using spacing again everything is done
in python and for the similarity and
competitiveness um we require input from
uh the other historic reports as
outlined before
let me give you an example of the
sentiment extraction
so here we start with uh some filter
text oh and for the stopwatch
punctuation
and lowercase all the words so we end up
with a bag of words
um
where we then uh keep only the sentiment
bearing words so in this case it's only
negative words
and we compute the sentiment as the
number of positives minus the number of
negative words normalized by the total
web count and we end up here with a
negative sentiment of minus 4.3
for readability i've also
found an example in the business
descriptions from different
annual reports
and
here we can see that in the top
example we have 24 words in the sentence
so this doesn't pass our threshold for a
long sentence which is 25 words
and an average word length of 6.6 and
with syllable count of 2.0
and in the bottom example we see a much
longer sentence of 67 words
and here we also see an increased
average word length and increased
average silver count which all points to
a
lower readability score
for this example
for similarity
i would like to show you an example from
the risk factors section
of the quarterly reports by the same
firm one from q2 and one from q3 and
2019
so the first one
mentions risks about their ability to
develop cbd infused beverages and comply
with laws
whereas in the um
second quarterly report we see a
different risk that they have
experienced recent broad term
over causing uncertainties and potential
harm to the business
and of course if we measure similarity
or we use the cosine
similarity
um based on the t of idf vectors we end
up with a very low scores between those
two documents
um so this was quite interesting to look
at in the context
of the recent or ongoing pandemic um
because of course we were wondering if
there were um
risk factors or if many firms were
mentioning the pandemic is risk factor
and here we looked at the risk factors
section in quarterly reports that were
filed in may 2020
and um this the graph shows a histogram
of the cosine distance the previous
report so now it's uh
the sign is flipped around high
means that they're very dissimilar
[Music]
and here we see a very unusual
distribution where a large number of
reports
show a high distance to the previous
report
we did we verified this looking at
examples so we didn't verify it for all
of the reports but in all the examples
we found
that there was a new
risk factor related to covet 19 that was
included
in the quarterly report
so
this is quite
interesting that the similarity is
actually able to capture this
so then we wanted to
evaluate the potential of
the textual signal in
a portfolio context
and we ran a portfolio simulation of the
u.s stocks
and we constructed a filings factor that
combines sentiment similarity and
readability metrics with equal rating
the stocks are then ranked according to
the filings factor
um and here we look uh we show the
top 20 so the top queen tile which is
the blue line and as you can see it
outperforms the benchmark
quite significantly while the bottom
quintile um so the
bottom ranked 20
um
falls back and falls below the benchmark
so this looks uh
like a promising signal to us
however we also identified some
challenges uh with the textual metrics
that we hope to address in the future um
so at first there is no mechanism to
address work sense ambiguity or context
dependency
of course they're more involved
sentiment
extraction methods for example but here
especially the document length presents
a big challenge for applying those
um we also observed that the similarity
metric uh does not differentiate between
dropping or adding the same text so um
and we observed examples of this during
the code pandemic as well so
we also saw uh some firms that had a big
change in similarity in july because
they dropped the covert risk
factor actually
and finally we're using a fixed
vocabulary so any neologisms were
currently unable to capture
so in the end let me describe a little
bit more the competitiveness metric so
in this example um
we could imagine uh
oh we could look at a coca-cola report
and here we see that a number of
food and beverage companies are
included as competitors and then we
apply
the page rank to the entire citation
graph of companies
so this is illustrated here again
so the pagerank algorithm of course
weights nodes higher that receive a
large number of incoming links incoming
citations um while themselves uh
having few outgoing citations so in this
case the company b which is cited by a
and c would receive the highest page
rank
[Music]
while
the others are a bit lower
and an interesting
example from our data
is can be seen when we look at amazon
so in 1999 amazon was viewed as a
competitor solely by barnes and noble
because of course they were selling
books
while
in
2019 20 years later we see
a large number of companies from many
different sectors
such as retail specialized trade but
also software and cloud providers that
all mention amazon as a competitor
in their reports
so of course amazon is
ranked quite highly
according to our competitiveness metric
we then also tested the competitiveness
metric in a portfolio simulation
where at first
it looks quite promising again you can
see blue line
but we then ran some further tests and
we observed that there was a strong bias
towards technology related stocks
um and unfortunately when we controlled
for this fires
um
by standardizing over the different
sectors
we found that the editorial was actually
uh
diminished
and uh unfortunately um in our
investment approach we
construct diversified portfolios over
the sectors so we were we were not able
to include competitiveness as a signal
so this brings me um to the end of my
talk um i hope to
have given you some insights about
working with company filings and also
some of the challenges that entails
for us the main takeaways were the
textual signals can be extracted from
company filings
but that the process is quite involved
and requires a technology stack
we've also seen that variation in
document structure
and changes over time require data
quality monitoring to ensure consistent
coverage we've seen that the sentiment
similarity and readability factor show
good results in simulated portfolios
while at the same time we saw that
some factors such as in our case that
competitiveness metric while promising
an academic setting
may have characteristics which can make
them unsuitable
to integrate
in practice
thank you very much and um if there any
questions i'll be happy to take some now
uh thank you laura for the presentation
and
we do have some questions for you uh so
let me just uh direct it uh the first
question is why the benchmark is a
horizontal
um so we basically show the index the
cumulative index uh value
uh relative to the benchmark so here the
benchmark is horizontal
all right all right
uh the other question is how long does
it take to process all historical data
and how long for daily processing
um so the historical data um is about uh
i think a week it took us um
so yeah so not too long uh if you do it
in parallel
um
daily process is um i think one or two
hours
all right all right
uh moving on to the next question uh
what happened between
2016 and 2017 where the portfolio value
suddenly shifted up that was on slide
number 27 is it related to the number of
reports released
um
so uh we we were wondering about that as
well i i might
my suggestion would be that um because
it gives a lot of weight to those tech
stocks it could be due to the the tech
rallies so those stocks really are
performing really well
um after uh 2016.
um
but
yeah it might be uh i guess we we
do need to dig a little bit deeper
into that as well
all right all right thank you uh so
seems like uh these are the only
questions that i have for now uh by the
way we still have a couple of minutes
left so if there's any question please
uh audience or regardless
uh so the question is uh were you able
to capture all of the competitive
competitors from the text
um
so there's um
oh
i'm trying to unless a bit
but um
i think we did we did quite well of
course there's
there might be some losses
because well of course that's how nlp
systems work you might always miss some
um
but i found that that space you did
quite well in identifying the entities
um the challenges uh or the bigger
challenge we found was um actually
mapping the entity strings
to the
standardized company names in our
database so there was a lot of
manual labor
and checking and rechecking and moved to
ensure that we that we captured or that
we got a good coverage
all right yeah i mean uh yeah nothing is
perfect you know you missed something
awesome so yeah that's totally
understandable uh so we all we got
another question uh seems like the
question is coming up so the question is
how long in the future can you use this
text to estimate relative performance as
you were looking for long-term signal
um
so i know there are some studies on this
in the literature that that found that
the signal um
is quite reliable i don't have a number
for you at the moment um but uh you're
welcome to hit me up in the chat later
and i'll try to
find it out for you
all right all right uh thank you uh so
we are almost at the time uh so thank
you a lot for joining us today and was a
lovely presentation and see you around
thank you bye